dos sanciones principales primero
congelar los activos que tiene el banco
detrás ruso en eeuu y también el
departamento del tesoro anuncia
sanciones duras contra un fondo de
inversión ruso que es manejado manejado
por un aliado de vladimir putin esto
quiere decir entonces que rusia no podrá
usar los fondos que tiene en dólares y
que tiene en eeuu también esto es
importante porque como lo decía janet
yellen la secretaría del tesoro limitará
significativamente la financiación de
rusia en la guerra que avanza con
ucrania y es importante mencionar
también que ningún estadounidense pues
podrá hacer transacciones con el banco
central ruso o con este fondo de
inversión sin embargo es de resaltar que
el departamento del tesoro hace una
excepción excepción a las transacciones
que se hacen con rusia en cuanto a el
gas y el petróleo es decir se le podrá
seguir pagando a rusia en dólares lo que
negocia con eeuu en cuanto a gas y
petróleo que ha sido una de las
sanciones que en muchos muchos analistas
pedido acá que se sancione a rusia que
no se les siga pagando por su gas y
petróleo porque ahí precisamente es
donde más bien en los fondos que usa
rusia o que está usando rusia en esta
guerra sin embargo pues ha tenido
consecuencias y hoy el banco central
ruso sube sus tasas de interés del 9 por
ciento al 20